welcome back to cbs mornings we're going
to take a closer look at the case
against elizabeth holmes a jury
convicted the theranos founder of four
counts of defrauding investors yesterday
one of her former employees was the
first to blow the whistle about the
problems at the company tyler schultz
says he quit after holmes and her
partner sonny balwani ignored his
complaints about falsified research he
then shared his concerns with the state
regulator and then he went to the wall
street journal tyler by the way is the
grandson of former u.s secretary of
state george schultz who was on the
board of theranos first on cbs mornings
tyler schultz joins us to respond to the
holmes verdict tyler good morning we're
really glad to talk to you this morning
first let's start with the verdict it
was a mixed verdict did the jury get it
right do you think
uh i think on at least four counts they
did get it right yeah
what do you mean
the four counts were again so she was
voting the investors yeah
yeah so there are four counts that they
uh had a guilty verdict for defrauding
investors but there were another four
counts that were for defrauding patients
um and those four she was found not
guilty
um and then there were an additional
three others where there was no verdict
that was reached
um but for me
one was enough so i'll take four what
when was that tyler i have to say you
seem in a very good mood this morning i
was wondering how you were going to feel
because listen a lot of people are
applauding what you did you were a 24 23
year old who had worked at the company
for less than a year
you realize the emperor had no clothes
you raised the issue with elizabeth
holmes with mr balwani with your
grandfather with your mother there were
fractures in the family you were told to
stand down and you did not why did you
keep going when you were up against so
much power
yeah i mean
it was tough there were a lot of moments
when it was really really tough to keep
going but
i am just extremely stubborn and i knew
i was right and i was not going to
lay down and
say that i was wrong when i knew with a
hundred percent certainty that i was
right
why do you think that they believed her
over you someone who was on site there
at the company and could see what was
going on why do you think people even
closest to you did not believe you
well elizabeth is a very very
charismatic person when she speaks to
you she makes you feel like you are the
most important person in her world in
that moment
and she almost has this you know reality
distortion field around her that people
could just get sucked into
even i when i was working with the
product every single day seeing it fail
time after time after time i could go
have a five minute conversation with
elizabeth and feel like i was saving the
world again
um it's it's really a hard phenomenon to
explain but she sucked a lot of people
in into that um that's that's that's
well expressed i think our viewers
should know that this is not just about
investors there were people who got bad
results from from this product a woman
who thought she had hiv another woman
who thought she uh what might be
miscarrying a baby so the stakes were
huge for patients as well
from your perspective from where you're
sitting i'm really curious about the
personal side of this this is your
grandfather george schultz a titan of
the 20th century former secretary of
state your relationship with him got
really rocky at one point you were
communicating only through lawyers what
kind of cost did you face as an
individual as a grandson and taking on
this fight
yeah um that was extremely tough you
know this whole saga has taken a
financial emotional end tolls on my
relationships and my gran the toll that
i took on my grandfather's relationship
was was probably the worst
um
i mean
it
it was it's tough to explain um
i had a few very honest conversations
with him
we uh ultimately did reconcile he never
quite apologized but he at least um
admitted that i was right about what i
saw and he congratulated me for doing
the right thing
and actually in one of my last
conversations with him he told me a
story about how he got elizabeth invited
during fleet week in san francisco to go
give a speech to
united states sailors
united states navy sailors and he said
with tears in her eyes she told the room
about how she was so honored and humbled
that her life's work would be saving the
lives of united states servicemen and
women and he said he just could not
believe
that anybody could get in front of these
people who are willing to put their
lives on the line for our country
and lie directly to their face as
convincingly as she lied yeah a lot of
people i feel like him telling me that
story
yeah he's telling he's saying tyler you
were right
yeah
yeah i feel like him telling me that
story was him acknowledging that i was
right and he finally was starting to see
through her lies
tyler you are who you are because you're
willing to use your voice um and you
were on the list of witnesses who would
possibly take the stand
did you want to and if you did take the
stand what would you have said
um you know i it was kind of nice not
having to go testify i didn't have to
prepare
i also i would have been happy to
testify to get up there and have the
opportunity to tell my story under oath
um
what i would have said i don't think we
have enough time for that but i would
have said that you know that i could
have gone into into detail about how the
technology didn't work in the various
ways the technology didn't work i would
have explained my conversations that i
had with my managers with a vice
president with a ceo with a board member
with regulators with journalists you
know i had to talk to a lot of layers
before anything really started happening
and so if i were on the stand i probably
would have gone through all those layers
tyler you want do you want jail time for
elizabeth holmes
um
you know whether elizabeth holmes spends
time in prison or not um doesn't really
affect my life
um i'm happy that she
was um
found guilty for for these crimes
and i feel like i got my vindication
from that and i feel good about that as
far as the jail time goes um
you know whether it's 1 5 10
i i i don't really care as much i'm just
happy that she was found guilty i feel
like i won i'm vindicated
yeah
i'm glad you feel i'm glad you feel
vindicated it's a very brave thing you
did tyler very well you risked your
professional and personal life and i
commend you for that tyler schultz thank
you so much for joining us